a new report could challenge one of the
president's key defenses against
impeachment according to the New York
Times the president released the Ukraine
aid he's accused of withholding for
political gain only after he knew the
issue was the subject of a whistleblower
complaint at a rally in Florida last
night the president once again slammed
the impeachment process he's been
invited to appear at a public hearing
next week but he has not yet responded
wheeshes yang is traveling with the
president in West Palm Beach Florida
Ouiser what else are we learning oh good
morning Anthony and good morning to
everybody
two new transcripts were released
yesterday from closed-door testimonies
and we learned that there was tension
within that department that withheld US
military aid to Ukraine and at that
rowdy rally last night right here in
Florida President Trump once again
insisted he has done nothing wrong
they take this perfect call and they
want to impeach the president thank you
and a campaign rally in Florida Tuesday
night President Trump railed against the
impeachment inquiry claiming it was
falling flat with voters did you see
what's happening in the pumps everybody
said that's really booked but new poll
shows support for impeachment at 50% 43%
are against those numbers which have
remained steady since October suggest
weeks of public hearings did little to
change public opinion that might change
next week
with a new round of hearings but the
administration's House Judiciary
Chairman Jerry Nadler gave the president
and his lawyers until Sunday to decide
if they will attend the hearing so far
the White House has refused to cooperate
in the inquiry and blocked those and
president Trump's inner circle from
participating even though mr. Trump at
one point tweeted he would actually like
them to testify Democrats say the White
House froze US military aid to Ukraine
to pressure the country to investigate
the Biden's last week's Adlon testified
that I told him quote what he went from
Ukraine I said I want nothing there's a
quote I want no weird
while President Trump made those remarks
to his EU ambassador on September 9th
but a new New York Times report says the
president was briefed about the
whistleblowers complaint in late August
so he would have already known there
were concerns about a quid pro quo
meanwhile newly released transcripts
from the only official to testify from
the office that actually froze the aide
revealed to White House officials
resigned in part because of concerns
about withholding it in a new interview
President Trump distance himself from
Rudy Giuliani denying he ever sent his
personal attorney to Ukraine to get dirt
on the Biden's on his behalf Giuliani
back that claim telling CBS News the
president never sent me to Ukraine
however the EU Ambassador Gordon Sunland
testified he worked with Giuliani to
pressure Ukraine on those investigations
because the president directed him to do
so Gail all right we should thank you
very much